c'est un grand cortège ministériel qui a
traversé les petites rues de nuits saint
georges
une arrivée en milieu de matinée pour
didier guillaume venu promouvoir la
montée en puissance de l'agriculture
biologique et de la vente directe à la
ferme fruirouge modèle du genre avec un
gros de cassis une visite du site et une
dégustation pour le ministre avant de
rejoindre les représentants du monde
agricole de côte-d'or
une rencontre à huit clos pour aborder
les conséquences de la sécheresse qui a
frappé le département cet été nous avons
déjà versé plus de 100 millions d'euros
à 12 départements dans le
département de côte-d'or qui a touché 6
qui va toucher 6 4 millions d'euros dead
à la sécheresse puis évidemment nous
avons évoqué aussi le problème de
l'irrigation en général mais pour
irriguer plus il faut stocker plus et
c'est là que ça coince
aujourd'hui monté à un projet pour
stocker de l'eau c'est très très
compliqué d'un point de vue
administratif lire ça demande des années
de procédures que le ministre nous a
écouté ça c'est sûr il fait preuve de
pragmatisme
maintenant on jugera aux actes dans
l'avenir par rapport aux décisions qui
va prendre le dialogue s'est ouvert
entre le ministre en fonction depuis
trois mois seulement et les agriculteurs
qui attendent du changement la fin de la
grille bashing et une meilleure
rémunération
j'ai quand même l'impression qu'il n'est
pas prêt à changer de paradigme on reste
sur une agriculture productiviste
sans s'occuper vraiment dû déboucher
mainini du producteur ni des gens qui
vivent autour mais que
on n'est pas prêt à remettre en cause le
système les changes aura duré un peu
moins d'une heure avec les agriculteurs
qui s'apprêtent à élire pour six ans les
membres des chambres d'agriculture